petit fait au regard clair et non dans
un sac imaginé
et donne donne amour et maryse est une
c'est une maman avec un grand m
avec un coeur gros comme un soleil au
jour le jour tout harper
ce que la vie
naples a côtoyé le tout bien
et juste part
depuis rodez fois le kilo wolf a d'abord
été une expérience personnelle l'arrivée
de cet enfant qui était pas comme les
autres dans notre foyer avec tous les
repères qui qui explose un peu rien
n'est comme avant
et puis il faut quand même continuer
donc là réfléchit on a parlé à beaucoup
de gens et on savait qu'il fallait
avancer mais comment ça c'était là le
gros souci et en juillet 98 il ya un
petit groupe d'amis qui nous a qui nous
a rejoint et puis on a monté donc cette
association stimuler pourrait bien de
vivre qui au départ était une aide à
plomber uniquement et bien les gens nous
connaissent et les gens venaient nous
expliquer ce dont ils avaient besoin est
là un nouveau constat c'est que la
stimulation multisensorielle ne
convenait pas forcément à toutes les
familles donc comment les aider
autrement puisque pour l'instant on ne
faisait que ça et après avoir discuté
avec certaines certaines personnes de
l'équipe certains bénévoles de
l'association
il s'est avéré que les parents avaient
du mal à garder un temps où ils étaient
seuls
là l'enfant porteur de handicap demandé
beaucoup de temps beaucoup d'attention
et parents n'arrivais plus à trouver les
moments a profité d'abord d'être en
communauté avec d'autres enfants
et c'est vrai qu'elle apporte beaucoup
aux enfants est certainement qu'elle
reçoit énormément c'est absolument
passionnant et changer comme ça sans
scrupules sans
sans arrière-pensée en fait cette
méthode est basée sur un phénomène
d'adaptabilité cérébrale à partir d'une
lésion
c'est à dire qu'en fait on sait très
bien qu'il ya une capacité
d'apprentissage qui est viable est
possible très très longtemps qui doit
être le plus précoce possible a dit la
découverte du handicap
et lorsque l'on a eue de lésions
cellulaires ou cérébrale qu'on
al'impression finalement que tout est
terminé alors c'est complètement faux on
a un excédent cellulaire très important
au niveau de la masse cérébrale qui fait
que lorsqu'une cellule et baisers
d'autres cellules qui est peut-être
inutilisé de pouvoir prendre le relais
en refaire ce qu'on appelle une
suppléance est assurée finalement une
fonction qui paraissait complètement
inutilisable est impossible d'obtenir et
qui finalement va redevenir tout à fait
possible avec un apprentissage avec une
stimulation qui va permettre de recréer
des voix et un fonctionnement sur des
fonctions cérébrales qui était qui était
visé et nous semble qu'il allait
rapidement diffusé ce message de ce
qu'on faisait
pour toutes les familles qui se
retrouvaient dans l'antre du cac et qui
n'arrivent pas forcément eu accès à
l'information
donc on a constaté le journaliste la
ville qui nous a fait immédiatement un
article hélas les familles ont commencé
à nous contacter on a l'a reçu
plusieurs qui disait être dans l'impasse
à caen avait été l horizon où il fait ça
ses bras là c'est bon c'est bon si ça
juste pour
juste part
la différence ne devrait pas
tu l'as pas à bout de bras
l'enfant qui crie qui se tordent ans
et pour toi
comme un trésor
toujours patiente toujours qui
combien idées ont fait changer
faire avancer le nom de
en
grande ronde
je peux pas
d
tout l'amour dont tu nous parles
non
dieuze morts
d'un grand tapis blanc la fermière ouvre
les portes et les animaux se précipite
dans la cour de la mairie que le fermi
et là forcément elle tous les animaux de
la ferme
c'est un peu difficile pour quelles
raisons
quand ils nous ont quittés
il est recommandé d'être tous qu'elle
arrive pas beaucoup mais jamais nous
faut qu'elle comprenne c'est pareil moi
moi je joue la démarche et il faut un cd
ont fait l'équipe a donc jardin et
souvent je me fais déjà à macao six mois
on nous demande pourrait montrer que
soit ce qu'elle préfère je croise et les
douces et chansons se sont pas trop
longue
elle n'aime pas beaucoup les chansons et
aussi surtout les crises et cris des
animaux et les chants des oiseaux comme
ça des choses qui m'a qui m'a posé
problème aussi c'était mon
investissement par rapport à chloé et la
place des deux autres enfants cédric et
cyrielle et je me suis demandé si pour
eux c'était pas trop lourd que de vivre
au sein d'une famille ou le handicap que
l'association qui qui aidé pour le
handicap
vrai ancien de combes matière soit en
fait plutôt que de desservir tout ce qui
a été fait autour de ça les asociaux et
diesse et des ah bah vivre la différence
aider aussi à faire plein de choses
autour du handicap avec différents
différents autres enfants pour voir
aussi bas que leur soeur s'était pas
c'était pas aussi terrible que ça et je
pense que ça leur a donné une ouverture
d'esprit aujourd'hui ils sont ils sont
très tolérants ils sont très vivants et
puis une famille c'est pas c'est pas
toujours lisse et c'est cette image là
qui garde et qui donnent eux on assiste
aussi c'est le bénévolat les gens
viennent travailler entre nu mais avec
nous parce qu'ils se sentent viennent en
ce groupe parce qu'ils ont quelque chose
à apporter aux enfants et au reste des
adultes et puis surtout parce qu'ils
sont motivés pour travailler avec cette
catégorie d'enfants selon et christian
dans deux heures et raphaël dans l'autre
est ce que ça pour vous c'est jouable ou
pas on après et ils ont poussé le ciel
se lever et le ciel se levait ironique
une branche ils ont remis tellement de
branche au bout des branches que le ciel
m'est arrivé à sa place
il est allé là haut où on le connaît
aujourd'hui je m'appelle 4 si je suis la
maman de trois enfants mme colas 25 ans
alexandre 5 ans et demi et raphaël qui a
aujourd'hui quatre en quatre ans il ya
15 jours pour le parcours médical donc
la prise en charge sur l'hôpital tout
c'était très difficile très inhumain et
particulièrement un petit détail donc
concernant le neurologue qui a regardé
l'irm fait sur appel lorsqu'il avait 6
mois et nous attendions vraiment sa
réponse avec eux beaucoup d'espoir pas
forcément pour une réponse positive mais
une explication sur raphaël qui a six
mois était allongé à plat qui ne
répondait ni à la lumière new show qui
était complètement poteau nique et les
regarder comme ça à lille et rennes le
cliché en disant oh ben ça va vers un
cerveau ce bébé quand je pense
aujourd'hui je me demande comment on a
pu rester donc le papa de raphaël et moi
comme ça presqu'à lui dire merci mais
avec plein de souffrance dans ton dos
des mots si dur tandis rencontré le mari
raphaël avec deux ans passés il tenait
de jeu mais ne marchait pas et il était
très fermé à touche à mon avis du mal à
l'habiller
ne pouvait pas le tenir beaucoup
beaucoup de freins je veux dire et donc
je veux dire j'ai trouvé chez anne-marie
tout d'abord une écoute humaine une
écoute de maman et ça c'était très
important c'était la première fois qu'on
que j'avais l'impression je dis je et je
pense que bertrand xi avait l'impression
d'être compris compris et ne pas être
jugé ou ne pas être regardés comme des
imbéciles parce qu'on ne savait pas
telle ou telle chose et ça c'est
important
et donc on a commencé la stimulation
avec raphaël il va voir semaine ce
moment de partage
qu'on arrive à avoir avec al marri aussi
à travers raphaël parce que vraiment
elle donne beaucoup de sa personne pour
les enfants et ça c'est extraordinaire
elle est toujours là vas-y tiens tu me
donnes tout aussi dense avec doudou ah
ah ah euh euh euh ah ah ah toi ah ah oui
papa papa
papapapa paw paw paw paw paw paw paw paw
paw paw paw à toi oui très bien plus
fort parfum as tu fais pas pas très bien
bravo à les écoute on va faire un
nouveau sens oh oh oh oh oh
à toi non oh oh oh oh
à toi oui oh oh
à toi ô
c'est bien la joie elle est de tout
moment je pense qu'on ne peut pas on
peut pas évoluer avec avec ces enfants
là s'il n'y a pas une joie
déjà rien que le fait qu'ils soient là
qu'ils fassent confiance est qui et qui
parce qu'ils passent du temps à
travailler entre guillemets avec moi cc
c'est déjà une récompense qui est
extraordinaire et puis je crois que ce
qu'il donne en plus et ce qui me permet
de voir ma ma vie personnelle et ma vie
avec mes enfants sont cet angle là c'est
que bayal ya toujours ya toujours un
moment de gaieté il ya toujours un
moment où il va y avoir un fou rire un
mot particulier à un moment particulier
qui va faire que le handicap c'est c'est
pas toujours triste c'est pas toujours
quelque chose de lourd et de plomber
mais cette situation-là l'entraînent
aussi de merveilleux moments oui c'est
vrai elle fait partager des moments de
joie même les enfants et leurs familles
en leur apportant des activités alors
permet de battre chacun de leur côté pas
se retrouver seul et en importance et
activités en créant des manifestations
l'art permet justement de partager ce
moment ensemble ces moments de joie
alors dans cet exercice là on s'aperçoit
que plus le le cerveau est et dans la
connaissance et n'a pas besoin
d'impliquer la réflexion plus le
mouvement va être précis et quand le
cerveau est obligé de mettre en place
une réflexion le corse des organismes
vas-y on y va voilà qu'à deux fois 6 2 x
4 3 14 dans le foyer
il sert deux fois 9
il ne fera litres ou 2 x 10' va bien
aller en arrière deux fois 10 va deux
fois 9 18 devant 8 c est deux fois ne
souhaiterait à tort deux fois ci toutes
deux fois 5 nice deux fois ou 88 2 x 3 6
2 x 2 4 2 3 1 2 ok donc là on voit que
dès que il va solliciter ces mécanismes
de raisonnement le corps tout de suite
se désorganise tout relax tu te mets
dans une foule
le petit oiseau des bois est celui qui
qui crie quoi
cris au soleil merci un veuf luisant
pour se donner plus blanches chemine il
se roule à dans la farine super elle
pour comme un ruisseau que les enfants
poursuit
courez courez vite si vous le pouvez
jamais
jamais vous ne la rattrapera ma
chandelle ici est mort ici je n'ai plus
de feu ici bravo
pour moi l'important lâche tout
attention réelle lâche mal pour l'amour
de dieu n'a maman et une balle et moi je
suis une boule qui roule roule qui
roulent encore qui roulent ils se
roulent dans la farine
mais quand le verre était revenu à
blanche par une tombola à l'ordre le
verre tous déçus c'est un trou et
disparus le théâtre c'est eux c'est une
équipe c'est un groupe c des
personnalités différentes c'est des gens
avec lesquels je me retrouvais et
laisser maintenant une activité qui fait
qu'il fait vraiment partie de moi j'aime
j'aime jouer j'aime me retrouver sur
scène j'aime ce contact avec le le
public que j'aime tous ces moments qui
sont d'une force d'une force importante
cette expérience avec le théâtre a été
quelque chose de très enrichissant sa
d'abord été la rencontre avec avec tous
les personnages avec tous les tous les
comédiens donc des aventures humaines
intense est importante pour pour
certains et puis ça a été aussi la
possibilité pour moi de pouvoir
m'exprimer sans être sans être à de
marie mai sortir un peu de deux mois
pour pour intégrer un autre personnage
et j'ai eu l'impression à ce moment là
que la vie était beaucoup plus légère et
que ma tête se libérer et se libérer en
fait un peu comme quand comme quand je
chante donc c'est une activité qui pour
moi aujourd'hui a pris beaucoup
d'importance et dans laquelle je me
retrouvais je me sens bien
anne-marie bien c'est quelqu'un qui a
beaucoup de générosité
c'est quelqu'un qui tout ce qu'elle peut
faire tout ce qu'elle entreprend c'est
avec une grande réussite
elle a des dons extraordinaires et c'est
une femme sur qui et on peut compter et
qui a vraiment à coeur vaillant crocs
comme un soleil
je pense que c'est tout à fait ça en
vrai soleil qui ai mis la vie de
beaucoup de personnes et je crois que en
plus elle sera entièrement pas compte à
quel point elle est brillante et à quel
point tout le monde peut profiter de sa
lumière et de la chaleur
ouais quoi dire d'autre dannemarie en
fait c'est quelqu'un qui a une force
énorme et
et qui est capable de déplacer des
montagnes et c'est vrai que al marri par
rapport à ça va pas se contenter de
passer la montagne pour elle mais en
plus ça va essayer de frayer un chemin
pour que tous ceux qui sont dans la même
situation puisse aussi la suivre et que
ce soit moins difficile pour eux qui
n'est pas tout à refaire
et ça c'est quand même assez
exceptionnel parce que souvent la
société dans laquelle on vit aujourd'hui
à voir c'est être cru aussi altruiste
c'est vraiment pas bonne at on des c'est
aussi une raison pour lesquelles je
l'avenir peut-être pas un soleil oui
c'est ma mère donc voilà mais je sais
pas si je la représenterai comme un
solide pour moi mais mais presque elle
fait beaucoup de choses pour les autres
oui ça veut dire quoi elle ça veut dire
que m
elle prend tout son temps et enfin tout
temps qu'elle peut avoir l opel
elle en profite pour faire des choses
avec les
enfin sur des choses avec les autres les
enfants handicapés les
les personnes qui ont besoin et du coup
voilà c'est elle fait pas beaucoup de
choses pour elle en fait elle donne tout
pour les autres et
après une certain temps de descendre aux
enfers j'ai décidé qu'il fallait réagir
parce que la vie c'était quand même
quelque chose de très beau et donc j'ai
décidé de réagir le respect on peut dire
j'ai décidé d'eux je ne sais pas j'ai
réagi quoi qu'il en soit et cette
association stimuler pour aider à mieux
vivre a pris tout son sens et par par le
biais de cette aide que je pouvais
apporter aux parents je faisais un peu
un pied de nez au destin en en disant
que pas ce qui m'arrivait et qu'au
départ je croyais fatale était en fait
pour moi une force une force pour
pouvoir aider d'autres familles qui se
retrouvaient dans le dans la même
situation pour moi
c'était quoi la consigne entendu quand
on entend le son
non c'est damon a les oreilles thermodyn
aléatoire et oui c'est difficile
d'attendre son tour allait passer quatre
mois maintenant tu veux pas si sûr
toutes ces personnes que j'ai
rencontrées tous ces enfants que j'ai
pris les tournées pendant un certain
temps vont apporter quand même beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de joie beaucoup de
satisfaction et je crois que rien ne
peut remplacer cette petite lumière qui
qu'on retrouve à nouveau dans dans
l'oeil dans l'oeil de ces familles qui
viennent on les reçoit au départ le
regarde et éteint et au fur et à mesure
chacun reprend confiance en l'avenir
chacun reconstruit un peu son projet et
je crois que si si je peux souligner une
de mes réussites celle là en est une
une énorme et peut-être la première
marie c'est un être au grand coeur mais
toujours en recherche de qualité de
compétences aussi un mari c'est cette
pugnace it et qui rend toutes les choses
possibles
et ça c'est quelque chose de c'est une
qualité remarquable c'est une bombe
d'énergie c'est quelqu'un qui qui pète
complètement de joie de joie de vivre et
qui à cet énorme faculté de tirer autour
d'elle toutes les bonnes volontés
c'est quelque chose d'incroyable et puis
il ya une ya une disponibilité de tous
les instants il n'y a jamais un moment
où elle n'est pas là prête en service à
l'un ou à l'autre qui peut l'appeler je
me rappelle la première fois que j'ai
été en contact avec elle elle ne me
connaissait pas elle m'a rendu service
mais comme ça par pure gentillesse par
pur don de soi c'est quelque chose
d'être
dean rct 13,7 c'est énorme qualité aussi
d'avoir réussi à se faire reconnaître à
faire reconnaître les valeurs les
valeurs que qui sont portés par
l'association comme il ya une fois j'ai
entendu des gens dans le milieu du
handicap dans milieu social dans dans la
vie tout simplement dire à à anne-marie
ça ça c'est quelque chose aussi au jour
le jour tout à côté
ce que la vie est brisée
son choix doit il est tout fait
c'est peu tu veux aider
et
juste par rebours
juste pas
et si beau chacun prépare
son petit bout de ton été
par tout l'amour dont une opa
oh
mathieu ne sera commentée